(light upbeat music)
- So yeah, I really want to follow on
in this wonderful vein
of discussion and thought
that we've had so far today,
Thinking about this question,
"Making an Old Brain Young."
As I get older, I want to be younger,
so this is part of it.
But I really want to consider how we can
take lessons from
understanding the child's brain
and see if we can apply
them to the adult brain,
or the aging brain, or the
brain with neural pathology.
First, before I actually do that,
I really want to talk about the concept
of what a critical period is,
and just remind you that a
developmental critical period
is a period during which
time special experiences
are essential for the later
function of the brain.
That's because these
experiences are essential
for tuning up brain circuits.
I want to talk about that in
much more detail in a minute.
But a good example of
developmental critical period
that I have experienced, alas, myself,
is one for language learning.
Obviously, you can learn throughout life.
You can learn languages throughout life.
But learning a language
without an accent as an adult
is extremely difficult.
Whereas, as we all know
now, it's extremely easy
to learn many languages
perfectly as a young child.
This has been my regret my whole life.
Here's the concept, basically, which is,
if we could only understand the underlying
molecular and cellular mechanisms
that regulate these
developmental critical periods,
maybe we could then apply them,
either in native repair,
to reverse developmental neuropathology,
or maybe even as a cognitive enhancer
so I could learn French, for example,
without an accent.
Now, in trying to understand
how this works, obviously,
at the level of molecules and cells,
we really need to get into the brain.
It's possible to do this in mice models.
In fact, mice, as far as I know,
have not been learning
second or third languages.
But mice, just like us,
have binocular vision.
Here's the question.
Have you ever thought about
why it is you don't see double?
What's happening is you have two eyes,
and each eye is sending a complete view
of the visual world to your brain.
And yet we only see one view of the world
unless there's some pathology.
One of the reasons that
we don't see double
is because, in fact, the
neural circuitry for vision
brings the connections
from the two eyes together
in the central part of
the visual pathways.
Let me just show you a very simplified
diagram of that now.
The point is that the output
neurons from the eyes,
these RGCs, the ganglion cells,
send their connections to
central structures, like the LGN,
and then beyond that from the LGN
to the primary visual cortex.
Vision doesn't happen,
visual perception doesn't
happen in your eye.
It happens in your brain.
These first few steps you can see already
how the wiring is bringing
the two eyes together.
For example, one of these RGCs here
is sending its connection
across to this LGN.
Another one from the other
eye is sending its connection.
Already you can see that the information
from the two eyes is
beginning to be combined.
Then at the next stage in
information processing,
that information is
again even more combined.
In fact, there's a
rather rather beautiful,
in this case, left eye, right eye,
left eye, right eye, left eye, right eye
kind of intermixing of the
inputs from the two eyes.
Actually those intermixed inputs
make connections finally with
these little gray circles
and these connections
are the target neurons
that, voila, become the basis for
your binocular vision.
In other words, they're getting input
from both the right eye and the left eye.
Before I go further, I want to define more
what I mean about connections.
I'm talking about connections.
But what I really mean
in neuroscience terms
is synapses, the synapse.
What is a synapse?
Let me just define a synapse.
A synapse is the junction or connection
between one neuron and the
next neuron along the line,
passing information, and by the way,
also doing some computations,
as the information is passed.
In fact, you are your synapses.
What I mean by that is,
your synapses get tuned up
during developmental critical periods.
Even if you are genetically identical
to your sister, your twin, or whatever,
in fact, your brain synapses are different
because the pattern of tuning
is slightly different in each case.
So you are your synapses.
Synapses change with learning.
Memories are stored at synapses.
Sadly, in Alzheimer's
disease, synapses are lost.
Let's just remember
that as I talk further.
Now, what's amazing is
that in animal models,
it's possible to visualize synapses.
We can go down to the
level of just a few microns
and actually see and test synapses
and understand how they
work in the animal models
like in the mice, or
even in higher mammals.
Many years ago this experiment was done,
and it's actually possible to visualize
this really beautiful left eye, right eye,
left eye, right eye, left
eye, right eye pattern
of synapses in the visual cortex.
I just want to show you
a very famous picture now
from David Hubel and Torsten Wiesel's lab.
At this scale, let me just point out,
these white blobs over here on the left,
they're supposed to be grains of rice.
This gives you some sense of scale.
Those are grains of rice.
Here you see one eye,
let's say the right eye,
was labeled with a white tracer substance
that gets all the way to the visual cortex
and labels all the synapses that are
functionally connected
to the white right eye.
So you can see, just what I told you,
that there's this beautiful
right eye, left eye,
right eye, left eye, right
eye, left eye striping pattern.
At this scale, what you're
looking at really is
hundreds of thousands of
these synapses at this scale,
where every little dot is
about the size of a synapse.
Now, when neural
scientists first discovered
this beautiful striping pattern
of synaptic connections,
they thought it had to be hard wired.
It's much too beautiful,
much to reproducible,
to be left to chance.
But in fact it turns out that during
a postnatal critical
period of development,
this pattern has to be tuned up.
In other words, even
using both eyes together
for binocular vision requires
an experience-dependent period.
In fact, one way that this was discovered
is in trying to understand
what's different
between childhood cataract and cataract
that you might get as an adult,
or your grandmother might get as an adult.
Where if you have normal
vision your whole life,
and then you lose vision in one
eye for some period of time,
when the optics are corrected,
then you can see again
perfectly as an adult.
That's because these
beautiful stripes are stable.
However, during a developmental period
these stripes are not stable.
They're getting tuned up.
If a child has a congenital cataract
that's not corrected
early on in development,
then the eye that's good gets way more
than it's fair share of territory,
so way more white synapses
in the visual cortex
than the bad eye gets.
The bad eye actually loses
synaptic connections.
In fact, those connections are pruned.
Jay referred to this.
I think several of our previous speakers
talked about this idea of a period
when there's a lot of synaptic remodeling
and pruning going on.
That's what I want to
really talk about now.
Let me just summarize by saying,
what you see now before your eyes
is a really beautiful example
of synaptic plasticity,
that is, the ability of a neural circuit
to change its pattern of
connections based on use.
This is an experience-dependent change.
In this case, it happens only during
a developmental critical period,
in the sense that after the
critical period is over,
which in us is around the age of six,
these connections become stable,
and they can't change this
dramatically at later ages,
which is why Grandma can
see even after having
a cataract for a long period of time,
whereas the child, if the
cataract isn't fixed quite soon,
will be permanently blind in
the eye that was not used.
This is a real use it or
lose it kind of thing.
Let me just summarize
here again by saying then,
that the baby's brain, just
like the adolescent's brain,
is not a miniature version
of the adult brain.
It's a dynamically changing structure.
Part of the change that's happening,
and we can see it in the animal models,
like mice, for example,
is that there's this synaptic remodeling.
Synaptic plasticity is the basis for
these developmental critical periods.
During this time, many immature synapses,
the ones that are used get
strengthened and stabilized,
and the ones that are not are pruned away.
There's a kind of pruning
versus a growth period.
So now the question is, how
in the world does this work?
How is this happening?
If we could only understand it,
we could restore plasticity,
maybe, to the adult brain.
But in order to do it, we
really have to understand
what are the underlying
molecules and mechanisms
that actually are responsible
for this kind of pruning process.
Many years ago, we worked very hard
to discover molecules that
might be involved in pruning.
I want to tell you about one.
This molecule is a big mouthful.
It's called PirB.
It's called paired
immunoglobulin-like receptor B.
It's very cool that it's a receptor.
The reason I emphasize that is because
if you have a receptor it can be targeted
for a drug or a pill.
As I said, this is like my dream,
but we're not there yet.
But it's good that it's a receptor.
The question is, how can
we show that this molecule
is actually involved in plasticity.
One way that it's possible,
in a mouse anyhow, is,
well, first I should
say that this molecule
is present in the brain.
It's in the neurons.
Happily, it's in our
favorite parts of the brain
that we like to study all the time,
the visual cortex in the mouse,
and the hippocampus in the mouse.
So it's there.
Now, how can we actually
study its function?
Well, in mice it's possible to remove
that particular molecule by taking away
just that gene from the
whole genome of the mouse.
There are 30,000 genes or so,
and one can remove just that gene,
from the very beginning of
development, for instance.
We can make, what's known
as a PirB gene knockout.
We can then either remove the gene
from the very beginning of development.
Or if we're really fancy
we can take it away
at any time of life, and then we can test
is this gene needed for
whatever, synaptic plasticity.
The bottom line is, what we discovered,
is that in fact, in these gene knockouts,
in fact there is, not
only is the gene needed,
but there's actually more
synaptic plasticity than normal.
I'm happy to talk about this later,
but just take my word for it.
PirB is needed for synaptic plasticity.
Then we asked how is this happening?
What is actually going on?
You already know the
answer, because I told you.
I told you that synaptic plasticity
involves both pruning and strengthening
of certain connections.
So we thought, let's look at pruning
in these PirB knockout mice.
To make a long story
short, what we discovered
is that pruning is deficient.
The way we did this
experiment was to label
some of our favorite neurons in the brain,
these little green dots, with
a green tracer substance,
and then we could actually look at
very high power, over here.
We could look at these
little protuberances,
which are the sites of the synaptic inputs
to these particular neurons.
Then we could count them all.
When we did that experiment
in normal, wild type
versus PirB knockout
mice, what we discovered
is that there were actually
way more of these connections
in the knockout mice than
in the wild type mice,
and that actually persisted
all the way into adulthood.
What we'd actually discovered is that
somehow PirB is required
for synaptic pruning.
In the absence of PirB,
so in this knockout mouse,
what we discovered is that
pruning was deficient.
The seesaw went in favor
of synapse formation,
genesis, and stabilization,
and away from synaptic pruning.
Okay, now there's a lot more
one could say about this.
But actually what I really
want to talk about is,
boing, a lightbulb went off for us.
Actually, a few lightbulbs
went off for us.
But I want to tell you about one.
Here's the lightbulb.
The lightbulb is that
in Alzheimer's disease
there's excessive synapse pruning.
This is thought to be
caused, at least in part,
by these bad plaques and
tangles that are formed
by the accumulation of a
substance called beta amyloid,
which actually conglomerates to make
very large plaques and tangles.
It's thought that this beta amyloid
is part of what's responsible for
loss of memory in Alzheimer's disease.
So question is, is PirB involved?
Because remember, PirB
is needed for pruning,
and here we have too much
pruning in Alzheimer's disease.
How would you study that?
Well, we've studied it in a
large variety of different ways.
But the first way is, PirB knockout mice,
please meet Alzheimer's disease mice.
What do I mean by that?
Neuroscientists can make
mouse models of disease.
What they can do is they can actually
put into the mouse the human disease gene,
the mutated gene.
Sadly for the mice, but thank you mice,
the mice can then end up
with the human disease.
In the case of Alzheimer's mice,
there are a variety of models.
In this case there are two genes
that are known to cause
early-onset family Alzheimer's.
Both of these are put into the mouse,
and the mouse, at about
nine months of age,
gets the plaques and tangles,
and sadly also a serious memory loss.
What we did is we decided,
let's see what happens if we remove PirB.
Remember, if we remove PirB,
then there's no pruning that happens.
What happens in Alzheimer's
mice that don't have PirB,
and amazingly when we studied
their memory performance
at nine months of age, they were protected
from memory loss in the
absence of the PirB molecule.
That actually kind of makes sense.
It's rather exciting.
At least to me it is.
How does this happen?
Again, to make another
really long story short,
what we discovered is this PirB receptor
is actually hijacked by this beta amyloid.
What do I mean by hijacked?
What I mean is that PirB, as I said,
is a receptor, which always
gets everybody excited
in terms of making drugs.
A receptor is a protein on a cell
that does work for the cell.
It takes information
from outside of the cell
and it actually transfers that information
to the inside of the cell
where it can do work.
In the case of PirB, that information
is part of the pruning process.
There are normal ligands for PirB,
including this thing called MHC class 1.
What we think is happening
is that beta amyloid
is also binding to this PirB molecule
and driving pruning to excess.
The other point I want to
make is that it turns out
that there are actually
human homologues of PirB.
There are quite a number of them.
What we discovered is that one of them,
called, another mouthful, I'm not even
going to write it out for you,
it's called L-I-L-R-B-2.
So it's very similar to PirB.
This human homologue also binds,
it seems to be hijacked by beta amyloid,
and it's also present
in the human forebrain,
and the signaling caused by binding
of beta amyloid seems to be also derailed
in the same way in the
human Alzheimer brain
as it is the mouse brain.
Now I'm going to summarize.
What I've suggested is
that Alzheimer's disease,
which is thought to be a
problem of synapse pruning,
may be driven by beta
amyloid-PirB interactions.
Definitely worth following that up.
So pruning is accelerated in this case.
What it also suggests to us is
there might be a pill in there after all.
What's great is that we
could even maybe make a pill
based on the fact that
there's a receptor here.
We know exactly what to do.
In fact, we have made a little pill
and tried it out in mice.
The last point I want
to make is stay tuned.
I think it's really interesting that PirB,
or LilrB blockade might represent
a slightly different therapeutic approach
for treating Alzheimer's,
but maybe also other pruning disorders.
Now, this might be
good, in that sense that
I don't know if you read recently,
but there was another failure of another
major Lilly Alzheimer disease drug trial.
It's really, I'm like, I'm getting older.
I would really like something soon.
I want these trials to succeed.
But maybe there's a pill.
But even more interesting I think is that
in fact lessons from neural development
may offer new treatment avenues
for Alzheimer's disease and
other pruning disorders.
With that, I just want to thank everyone.
Thank you all.
Also, I want to thank our organizers.
I have to remind everyone
that this experiment was done,
these kinds of experiments,
with many, many
students and colleagues and someone,
and I would also like to thank the mice.
Thanks, everyone.
(applause)
(light upbeat music)